I've got statement I would like to make
them pop my clients it's directed
towards the to operator in this case
Thomas Cook
thomascook you are a multi-million pound
operation you take money from families
like this family who expect to go on
holiday and have the time of their lives
they don't expect to return from holiday
with their children and coffins because
Thomas Cook staff failed to properly
check the standards of the hotel they
stayed in these children the jury had
found were killed unlawfully as a result
of criminal negligence no proper
explanation has been provided as to how
this happened
Thomas cook should hang its head in
shame as a result these deaths the
families of Christian Bobby have waited
nearly nine years for an apology
they are still waiting when invited to
apologize last week the chief executive
of Thomas Cook said I have nothing to
apologize for
well mr. Frank Houser today this jury
found that your star fail to carry out
proper monthly help and safety audits
your staff were not given proper
training your safety checks we're not
carried out vigilantly we asked will you
say sorry now Thomas cook should stop
the excuses show respect to these
families and the memory of Bobby and
Christi who died on a thomas cook
holiday thank you very much Sharon wood
would like to say a few words and then
Neil Shepherd will be worse